how do you feel that brainstorm is going
to be released I don't know I hear it's
going to be released I have some a
little bit of looping to do as a matter
of fact this weekend on it I haven't
seen it I never hear anything about it
untimely death of Natalie Wood during
the filming of brain storm did that make
that entire experience painful for you
oh sure on so many in so many ways it
was a terrible thing did having a
co-worker and a friend die change your
attitude about living Christopher well I
suppose you know confrontation with the
sudden absence of somebody you're
working with and you know for anybody
you know it's bound to make a difference
in your life yes how do you feel about
the way the media handled the fact that
Natalie Wood did die during the shooting
of brainstorm how do you think that was
dealt with they handled it you know in
the only way they could it was a
shocking thing and I think everything
that happened
it's gonna happen
do you think that the real story of
Natalie Wood's death has actually come
out the real story of her death is that
she drowned and nobody knows how she
drowned
what happened except that's what it is
there is no real story
there's nobody want to know
[Music]